Let’s talk about the geometry of how images
are formed. All images start with light coming
from some source of illumination; perhaps
the sun, perhaps indoor lights in the ceiling
of a building and that light reflects off
objects in the world. Some of that reflected
light ends up in our eyes. There are two types
of reflection. There is the mirror-like reflection
we call specular reflection and there is the
reflection from a diffuse or matte surface,
which is called Lambertian reflection.
Most surfaces are a mixture of specular reflection
and Lambertion reflection. But irrespective
of the sort of reflection that’s occurring,
we have light from a light source reflecting
off objects and some of those light rays are
going to enter our eyes. Let’s look at this
in a graphical representation.
Once again, we have our observer of the scene.
We have a three-dimensional object in the
world and we’re going to consider what happens
at just a few points on that particular object.
So the first thing we need is a source of
light.
We turn on the sun and what’s going to happen
now is light is going to be reflected from
the sun at a number of these points and some
of those light rays are going to enter the
eyes of the observer.
When we look at a three-dimensional statue
like this either through a camera or with
our own eyes, we experience a very vivid and
crisp image of that object. But if I simply
hold up a piece of paper here and it is receiving
light that’s reflected off the statue, then
no matter how hard or how closely I look at
this paper, there is no concept of image being
formed on here. We need to organize the light
rays, which are leaving the statue in order
to get a crisp image.
So let’s look at this problem graphically.
We have an image plane, the piece of paper
that I just held up and if I consider any
particular point on that image plane, the
light that’s falling on any single point
could have come from any number of points
on the three-dimensional object. What’s
happened is the light from all of those points
is being mixed up so that if I just hold up
a piece of paper no coherent image will be
formed on that.
What we need to do is to order the light rays
in some way and the simplest way to think
about doing this is to put an opaque plane
in front of the image plane and to drill a
small hole in it. This is a configuration
that’s referred to as a pinhole camera.
What this does is order the rays that are
leaving the points on the object and it causes
an inverted (that is an upside-down image)
to be formed on the image plane. This approach
to imaging is called a pinhole camera. Sometimes
it’s called a camera obscura and it’s
been known since ancient times.
This picture shows a building with a small
hole drilled in its wall and what’s happening
is that there is an image of the bright sun
outside is being cast on the interior wall
of the building.
Here are some examples of pinhole camera images
that I’ve downloaded from the web. People
have observed these images perhaps they’ve
been inside a darkened room, there’s been
a bright scene outside, a bright sunny day
and there’s been perhaps a hole on the blind
or window covering and that has caused an
image of the outside world to be cast on the
wall.
Now recall from the previous example that
this image is inverted. So in the left-hand
image, the person like turned their camera
upside-down and you can see an electric toothbrush
hanging from the top and in the right-hand
image, you can see the fact that the pinhole
image is in fact inverted. Here is an example
of a very, very large pinhole camera. This
was an amazing project that happened in a
disused aircraft hangar back in 2008. On the
left, we can see a bunch of people standing
in front of the image plane. That’s where
the image from the pinhole camera has been
cast and on the right-hand side, you can see
them endeavouring to actually capture that
image so they made a very, very large piece
of film, a very large negative and they’re
going to put it up against the wall and expose
it and capture an image using this pinhole
camera.
So, a quick refresher on what happens with
a pinhole camera. Rays of light leave various
points on the object. They all pass through
the pinhole and cast an upside-down image
on what we call the image plane.
The geometry of this pinhole camera is actually
very simple to describe. We’ll consider
that the object is at a distance Z away from
the plane of the pinhole and the image plane
is a distance F (F for focal distance) away
from the plane of the pinhole.
Then if the height of the object is Y, the
height of the image is y and these are two
similar triangles. So it’s very easy to
write the relationship over here. It simply
comes from the fact that we’ve got two similar
triangles. We can also do the same thing for
the horizontal plane. We introduce the symbol
X for the distance out of the page of the
object that we’re looking at and x for the
distance along the wall in the image plane.
We can again write the equations that come
from looking at two similar triangles. So
this image formation process maps a point
in the world with coordinates X, Y and Z to
a point on the image plane whose coordinates
are x and y. We can rearrange those equations
in this fashion.
So if x now in terms of the real world coordinates
X and Z and similarly for y. So this is what
we call a projection. It projects a three-dimensional
quantity X, Y, Z into a two-dimensional quantity,
x and y. It is a mapping between three dimensions
and two dimensions.
This referred to as perspective projection.
This is the mathematical basis for the process
that we’d call perspective projection. A
consequence of perspective projection is that
there is no unique inverse. If I have an image
of the object in the real world then there
are an infinite number of possible objects
that could cause that image. It could be a
small object that’s close to me or it could
be a large object that’s further away from
me.
One of the dimensions has been fundamentally
lost. From a two-dimensional image, we cannot
recover this third dimension. Now, in our
brains, we use a lot of tricks to try and
recover that third dimension.
We know something about the structure of the
world. We know something about the size of
objects. So if we see what looks like a small
person we think “No, no, no, it’s probably
a large person who is further away.”
So to recover the third dimension is fundamentally
impossible but there is other information
that we can bring to bear to recover it.